hey jacob are you ready
i'm a smug lady
[Music]
[Applause]
ugh
we got a fair amount of standing dead
wood we got a little bit of flat ground
i think we might be able to do it
oh
[Music]
household
um
so
so
i can see what the ground situation is
the ground's a lot more uneven than i
thought we've got about a one foot
difference between here and there i'm
gonna have to do something to deal with
that or it's gonna be a really rough
night
so
you
um
so
took some serious work but i got the
digging done check out my shelter
all right
[Applause]
whoa
big fire huh
oh
you stuck
were you trying to make snow angels
[Music]
there you got
[Applause]
we're accomplishing three things with
this fire one is we're making the
shelter a little bit bigger thawing out
the ground making it warmer and we're
leveling out the ground by burning out
all the stumps and moss and little
things so that we can have a nice flat
warm surface to sleep on
all right fire's been burning pretty
good for several hours we got a huge
pile of coals right in the middle so i
need to kind of push everything to the
side and get down on the ground and
inspect it and see how far we've come
then i only kind of need to spread the
fire around and get the spots that
haven't burned down evenly yet
i've pulled the fire down enough
five
so
so
ah
[Music]
well this is about as flat and level as
it's ever gonna be
i threw some dry pine valves down to try
to level it out better it also puts a
little bit of gap between the hides and
the wet ground so you're less likely to
soak through the hides and get wet all
right time to make up our bed we got
these caribou hides we're gonna sleep on
caribou have these hollow hairs that are
really thick and light this thing weighs
hardly anything it's super light but
it's like this thick and a great
insulator
you are getting toasty
oh yeah
that nice and warm
you
we got the tarp up and it's tight like a
drum
that'll be good all right time to get
our bedding out and i got my bison hide
here we're gonna lay that out
how you doing jake are you warm in there
here
there's your stuffed animal buddy
get my phone
well i've been shoveling and chopping
and sawing for six hours and so finally
we're to the part of the camp out that i
like the best
we're gonna sit and relax by the fire
cook some good food and hang out and
talk
jake you want some hot chocolate
but do you know how you spell his name
all right i think it's time to get some
dinner going
gonna melt a bunch of snow here
and we're gonna make some curry
all right we got some boiling bag rice
[Music]
my dinner
well i knocked my pot over and all my
potatoes carrots and rice fell on the
ground
the rice is in a bag so i'm gonna go
ahead and rinse that off and then and
try to salvage it well this is gonna
delay dinner about another hour but
luckily we came prepared
you got plenty of snacks no boys of mine
ever go hungry on trips what do you
think of the salmon
i think it's great
little smoked salmon's good stuff
gonna rinse it off and get it boiling
again
all
right um
nice bowl of japanese curry well my
curry only has onions and sausage in it
but it tastes pretty darn good
this reminds me of living in japan we
used to eat curry all the time
well we managed to salvage dinner so
we're just hanging out by the fire and
enjoying this beautiful full moon we got
out here tonight we're supposed to get a
lot of snow tonight so i should probably
reinforce the roof before i go to bed
there we go got the roof covered in
boughs so if we get a good dump of snow
tonight the tarpon cave in canyon
don't you want to sleep under animal
hides i don't know
you'd rather sleep with your sleeping
bag
yeah okay whenever i do these survival
camping videos with my boys i always
bring along their sleeping bags and
other little things just to make sure
that they're comfortable and have a good
time he's going to sleep in a sleeping
bag tonight and i'm going to sleep under
the buffalo hide
i'm gonna tell you what guys i'm gonna
bust out my thermometer because it feels
amazing in here and i want to see how
warm it is
you see guys it's not that cold out here
it's about 26 degrees fahrenheit outside
so it's a nice mild winter night all
right we're gonna set the thermometer
right there and see what the temperature
is
check it out we're at about 65 degrees
fahrenheit here at the shelter so we got
almost a 40 degree difference
for inside the shelter versus outside
it's really cozy in here before we go to
bed we're going to have a little snack
here got some yaki mochi
this is a block of rice
it's glutinous rice called mochi and you
barbecue it up and eat it with melted
butter and brown sugar it's
really really good something to eat in
japan around new year's i love this
stuff
oh gooey in the middle crunchy on the
outside
that is good
oh that hits the spot
i'll tell you what though this is as
cozy of a winter shelter as i've ever
made it is so much warmer in here all
right i'll see you guys in the morning
oh good boy
well it snowed on us pretty good last
night but we stayed warm
um bed wasn't too hard that's not too
bad oh i suppose i should get up make
some breakfast
ah
sounds like so much work
definitely got snow last night
uh
well there we go we got breakfast in our
bellies now we're just gonna
get packed up and uh luckily it's not a
ton of stuff to pack up
but everything's gonna be soaking wet
and dirty oh it's gonna be a lot of
cleaning after this camp out you wanna
stay in your sleeping bag
so
after burning all night the fire dug
about a five inch hole in the ground you
can see this all this top layer of soil
is just moss and organic material and it
was just burning through that we had a
fire going in the shelter for over 10
hours and i can feel the bottom here and
it we still haven't gotten down to soil
yet
takes a long time to burn down to the
dirt
did you have a good time jacob
well guys i hope you had as much fun
watching this as we did filming it if
you guys want to see more adventures
from the outdoor boys youtube channel
don't forget to click subscribe we put
out new videos every saturday morning we
have some amazing camping and travel
adventure playlists i'll put links in
the video description below thanks for
watching guys if you like this video
don't forget to check out the outdoor
boys youtube channel where we have
hundreds of videos just like this and
don't forget to click subscribe so you
can see other great videos every
saturday morning and hit that bell
button you'll get notifications thanks
for watching
click subscribe